[Music]
foreign
the park
paying attention
work I think I'm ready for Duty do you
feel ready I think it's the only as a
kid missing
what's the call I'm calling to report a
bank robbery is this crime currently in
progress today see that guy on the bench
do you have a lighter that goes up to
something
very hot today it's like a furnace
it's like a furnace
there's a safe deposit box
[Music]
but I'm the wrong man
where is she
I know you called the tip in on the bank
heist who the hell are you what makes
total strangers love an elaborate bank
heist are you familiar with the concept
of hypnotics hypnotics
hypnotics have the ability to influence
the brain sound
voice
blocking eyes do not excused them to
make you see a version of the world that
doesn't exist
oh thanks
saw him anymore next stop
[Music]
I have to know everything
why me why my daughter
I don't know what you're dealing with
what you see isn't real
goodbye
hypnotics make everything that you see
and do
perfectly normal
[Music]
foreign